[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 29
septembre après le conseil municipal de
montigny le bretonneux michel laugier a
fait ses adieux au conseil
d'agglomération alors que les
tractations se poursuivent à droite pour
choisir son successeur
fanny chantreuil notre invité fil rouge
pour cette émission président de l'unfp
terrasse au super excuse fédération
d'associations affiliées au syndicat
fage nous évoquerons avec elle toutes
les actualités de l'enseignement
supérieur plateforme apb tirage au sort
ou encore logement étudiant enfin dans
le reste de l'actualité locale nous
reviendrons sur le bilan touristique
dans les yvelines et les tensions à
maurepas autour de l'avenir du café de
la plage le nom du nouveau président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines sera connue donc fin octobre
michel laugier 7 sa place après son
élection au sénat ce jeudi soir il est
présidé sa dernière séance du conseil
d'agglomération
entre émotion et ordre du jour la soirée
était forcément particulière reportage
de wilfrid richy et nicolas landry il
tombe bien sûr sénateurs rigide et au
président 18 au goût je serai toujours
je serai toujours là pour servir de
l'avenir des vassaux 50 années c'était
sa dernière en tant que président de
saint quentin en yvelines michel laugier
a tenu à l'issue du conseil
d'agglomération a remercié ses
collaborateurs mais aussi à revenir sur
ces trois années de mandat
ce soir oui c'était la dernière séance
ce comme on dit dans tout cas je voulais
remercier tous les élus qui se sont
repliés et c'est vrai que les élus dame
de sion n'a pas la même vision des
choses
on est très attaché à d'autres
territoires aidé à toujours fait ça dans
l'intérêt de nos villes dans l'intérêt
de l'intercommunalité et je pense que
c'est la grande leçon qu'il faut retenir
alors que les discussions se poursuivent
en coulisses pour désigner un candidat
pour lui succéder la date du 19 octobre
semble aujourd'hui confirmée pour la
tenue du scrutin
ce jour là l'ensemble des postes sera
redistribué lors d'une séance
extraordinaire sur le fond de ce dernier
conseil du président logis aura surtout
été marqué par là
option à la quasi-unanimité d'une motion
de défense de la ligne 18 les élus
exigent que le métro automatique soit
réalisée d'ici 2024 pour soutenir le
développement du territoire
alors que des rumeurs insistantes
évoquent la suppression de la gare prévu
à guyancourt
par souci d'économie on peut pas avoir
des menaces comme ça alors qu'on s'est
battu depuis des années alors que tout a
été fait que le débat public a eu lieu
que tous les textes officiels sont
sortis quand on s'est engagé aussi dans
le cadre des jeux olympiques que aussi
aller les chefs d'entreprise sont montés
au créneau pour expliquer la nécessité
si on n'a pas de lille 18 y aura plus de
développement en termes de logement à
saint quentin en yvelines
il y aura plus de nouvelles entreprises
et qu'ils vont vouloir venir et
peut-être même que certaines vont
décider de nous quitter dans les
prochaines semaines des actions de
terrain sont également envisagés pour
maintenir la pression sur le
gouvernement ait des différentes
délibérations on retiendra l'attribution
d'un fonds de concours aux communes qui
pour maurepas et l'on courait coignières
est synonyme de feu vert à la
reconstruction d'un nouveau centre
aquatique
enfin les tarifs de la future vélo
station de la gare de saint-quentin ont
été adoptés ce nouveau service de
location sera facturé 2 3 à 15 euros par
jour 150 vélos classiques 10 vélos à
assistance électrique et 10 vélos
pliants seront proposés la mise en
service pourrait se faire en octobre et
donc vouloir incompris michel logis et
siégera à partir du mois d'octobre au
sénat dans les yvelines les résultats
sont largement favorables à la droite
vous le voyez à l'écran les républicains
raflent cinq des six sièges dans le
département elle la république en marche
elle obtient le dernier siège avec
martin lévriers en tête de liste à noter
que le président du sénat sera élu lundi
un poste qui devrait revenir une
nouvelle fois à gérard larcher
l'ancien maire de
embrouillé plateforme apb pour les
bacheliers tirage au sort pour l'entrée
à l'université ou encore les
propositions pour le logement étudiant
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal a présenté jeudi les
grandes orientations de cette rentrée
universitaire une remise à plat du
système pour l'intégration licence est
notamment prévu c'est le principal
chantier écouté la ministre sur ce sujet
les lignes définies par le gouvernement
sont est plus de tirage au sort à la
rentrée 2010 8 et la mise en place d'un
contrat de réussite pour lutter contre
la sélection par l'échec
pour cela nous ferons connaître les
attendus à acquérir pour une insertion
réussie dans une formation
les taux de succès en fonction des
baccalauréats et les taux de poursuite
d'études et d'insertion professionnelle
de chaque filière et pour évoquer
justement en cette rentrée universitaire
fanny chantreuil est notre invité en
plateau au bonjour vous êtes du coup la
présidente d'un terrasse au-dessus vs q
la fédération des associations
étudiantes de l'université versailles
saint quentin affiliés à la fage premier
syndicat étudiant tout est complet dites
nous comment comment se déroule cette
rentrée sur le terrain a levé est ce qu
est ce qu il ya des remarques
particulier des problèmes particuliers à
soulever des amphis bondés des élèves
qui ont pas trouvé les bonnes filières
ou alors tout se passe bien aujourd'hui
on peut dire comme l'actualité l'a10 au
niveau du national il ya eu des
problématiques surtout vraiment au
niveau de début septembre et des
affiliations avec apb là ici à saint
quentin en yvelines dans l'univers
c'était de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ya eu une
grande discussion avec le rectorat
l'université a réussi à obtenir 130
places supplémentaires pour accueillir
du coup les étudiants parce que la
demande était plus forte que plus
importante que l'offre sur ses 130
places il ya quarante places qui ont été
remplis par des étudiants donc on peut
considérer que vous avez un président et
un luxe presque dans le monde
universitaire on vous donne plus de
place et bah on peut dire que c'était
bien parce que du coup avec des
étudiants ont pu trouver ont pu être
acceptée avoir la possibilité d'aller là
où il voulait et de plus on a des élus
qui siègent dans les conseils de
l'université etc ont pu répondre du coup
aux problématiques des étudiants et les
aiguiller temps dans les différents
services ouverts les différentes
personnes pour réussir à obtenir leur
choix alors je le disais à l'instant la
grande annonce de cette rentrée si et la
fin de la plateforme apb sous sa forme
actuelle en tout cas est d'ici un an
cette plateforme qui permet aux
bacheliers de choisir leur orientation
via internet depuis 2003 ça fait 14 ans
que cette plateforme existe et il ya
encore beaucoup de dysfonctionnements
que vous disiez vous même cet été je
crois qu'il ya 3700 bachelier en france
qu'on pas trouvé de deux filières la fin
de ce système qui a maintenant 15 ans
vous en tant que syndicat étudiant vous
dites quoi c'est une bonne nouvelle il
était temps enfin alors nous en tant que
fédération des associations étudiantes
on s'intéresse surtout au local ce qu'on
veut c'est que les personnes qui ont un
qui ont des choix puisse obtenir les
choix qu'elles veulent je pense que
cette plateforme ya plusieurs pensions
qui a plusieurs réflexion à avoir
c'est la plateforme n'a pas pu répondre
aux besoins en tout cas et à la demande
de cette année forcément il ya il ya un
travail à faire il ya différentes choses
à apporter
on a quelques réflexions sur principaux
de zac je pense
l'orientation déjà avant
je pense qu'il faut une orientation pro
action commencée l'orientation dans les
premiers mois de la terminale par
exemple c'est ce que voulait dire
pourquoi pas même plutôt un
accompagnement tout au cours que l'on
dit c'est vrai c'est vraiment pour une
entame une orientation pour que les
choix qu'ils soient faits correspondent
aux personnes et que et que les haies et
qu'ils aillent dans les lieux où ils ont
envie d'aller
mais puisque aujourd'hui est ce qui
coince notamment c'est le fameux tirage
au sort c'est à dire que quand il ya
trop d'étudiants qui souhaitent aller
dans une filière et du coup qu'il n'y a
pas assez de place on tire au sort il ya
une forme d'injustice et ça c'est la fin
du système qui sera mise en place d'ici
un an ça c'est une bonne nouvelle on
peut pas de toute façon la comédie c'est
que c'est contraire à la loi ce n'est
pas c'est pas possible de tirer au
hasard des personnes pour le raffiner
leurs études supérieures et peut-être
impacter leur vie future
alors l'idée du gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est de mettre en place des pré-requis
c'est encore assez floue on sait pas
trop ce que ça veut dire
cette histoire de prérequis vous en
pensez quoi vous et comment vous
imaginez sa conception
aujourd'hui masse est encore en
réflexion là des groupes de travail qui
sont au gouvernement la fage fait partie
de ces groupes de travail
donc c'est par eux on peut réfléchir
aussi à apporter apporter des réflexions
je pense que sa demande à voir ce qui va
sortir un peu de ses réflexions et de
ses groupes de travail pour voir si
c'est adapté ça peut s'adapter
aujourd'hui au fonctionnement des
universités prônons prenons une option
imaginons que par exemple on disait à la
rentrée prochaine ans en 2018 s'il ya
trop d'élèves il y aura un test qui sera
fait en septembre pour éventuellement
révoqué ceux qui n'ont pas ceux qui sont
les moins bonnes notes est ce que ce
serait une solution viable ça par
exemple selon vous informe une forme de
test je pense élections en quelque sorte
je pense que c'est un dauphin le terme
de sélections
c'est compliqué à ses concurrents à
déterminer au jour n'est pas dessus
aujourd'hui on n'est pas sûr qu'on ait
la solution en fait à ces problèmes
c'est en réflexion et je pense qu'il
faut continuer à voir ce qu'il va émaner
de toutes ces réflexions la question
sous-entendu un peu sous ce débat qui a
lieu en ce moment vous le disiez les
groupes de réflexion mise en place par
le par le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur c'est c est ce que tout le
monde a vocation à aller à la fac même
si on a eu le bac est ce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas le problème c'est de ne pas
mettre en avant plutôt les bts les dut
plutôt que la faculté elle même vous
avez raison c'est ce que c'est ce qui
est discuté je pense qu'il va je pense
que forcément tout c'est toutes ces
choses vont devoir être évaluée
il ya un autre chose qu'un autre sujet
qui rentre en compte dans tout ça c'est
l'innovation pédagogique
c'est quelque chose qui va permettre
d'ouvrir aussi l'université aux
étudiants en tout cas innovations
pédagogiques c'est quoi ça veut dire
plus de cours via internet donc du coup
peut-être moins de monde dans les amphis
ce soir par exemple ça peut être ça ça
peut être des agences noms différents
il va falloir réfléchir à l'aménagement
de l'université où par exemple à
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
ses réflexions sur l'innovation
pédagogique ont déjà lieu depuis
quelques temps on voit des choses à
paraître il ya une plateforme pour les
mots qu vous a laissé les cours les
formations sur internet pour les cours
en continu qui s'est développée on a
dans nos bibliothèques universitaires
une learning lab ça va être un endroit
en fait pour faire des conférences avec
du matériel d'innovation pédagogique
donc en tout cas ici à l'université il
ya déjà des choses qui a mis en place et
on pourrait éventuellement piocher des
idées au sein de lever excuse pour pont
pour l'ensemble de pour l'ensemble de la
france
une réflexion sur sur sur l'actualité la
plus chaude et plus on enchaîne sur le
budget du ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur en hausse de 700 millions
d'euros c'est forcément une nouvelle qui
vous ravit j'imagine est-ce que ça
rattrape un peu cet été mouvementé d'
emmanuel macron qui avait annoncé une
baisse des appels et qui touchent
évidemment de nombreux étudiants même
ici à saint quentin en yvelines sur le
budget le budget du coup va impacter
l'université donc ça va être pour ça va
potentiellement leur donner les moyens
peut-être pas suffisant là où on va vous
aimeriez aller surtout pour répondre
encore assez haut peut-être pas encore
assez et et pour là pour pas forcément
répondre à la demande qui va encore
avoir lieu l'année prochaine
donc je pense que là il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à effectuer ce qui au
niveau des appels
oui enfin - 5 euros sur les appelle ça
peut paraître anodin anodin mais surtout
pas pour les étudiants en fin de compte
si on regarde sur une année 5e rang mois
par mois ça fait un budget pour un
budget d'un mois pour les transports en
commun pour un étudiant
c'est un saint un impact sur la vie de
l'étudiant et je pense surtout pourrait
on trouve surtout pour les étudiants qui
sont déjà en situation de précarité donc
donc là il ya des choses qui sont
négociés au nas qui sont discutées au
national et avec la fage qui nous permet
d'avoir un appui le logement étudiant
elle est en était d'ailleurs question
cette semaine dans les journaux de tv 78
lundi nouveau aux présentations la
solution inter-générationnelle une
personne âgée accueille chez elle un
étudiant cela permet d'avoir un loyer
moins cher pour l'étudiant est plus de
lien un sujet de nicolas landry elles
cohabitent ensemble depuis 15 jours
étudiant en licence d'environnement
ambre s'est installé chez lui s'il pour
cette année scolaire un binôme formé par
l'association spécialisée dans le
logement intergénérationnel
ensemble2générations elles sont toutes
les deux assez indépendante mais je
trouve qu'elle est jeune belle
connivence qui s'installe
je sentais qu'elle pourrait très bien
s'entendre parce que très ouvert toutes
les deux très respectueuse du planning
de chacun et puis en se donnant des
rendez-vous temps en temps pour partager
des dîners lucile prépare un voyage à
berlin
l'étudiante n'hésite pas à lui donner
des conseils pour son séjour
ensemble2générations a déjà constitué
650 binôme dans les yvelines depuis la
création en 2006 trois formules sont
proposées pour les étudiants et les
seniors soient les étudiants sont logés
gratuitement en échange de présents ce
soir et la nuit
sinon on a une autre formule où
l'étudiant va rendre des services
et là le jeune va payer une petite
participation aux frais d'usagé
d'environ 80 100 euros par mois pour
couvrir les frais de gaz électricité et
puis notre formule où le seigneur a
besoin d'un complément de revenus ou des
content aussi d'avoir une présence dans
la maison
ambre a choisi cette dernière option
elle paye un loyer inférieur à 300 euros
alors j'ai choisi ce genre de logement
parce que déjà d'un point de vue
économique c'est beaucoup mieux
et aussi et surtout parce que ça me
permet d'être en colocation avec
quelqu'un et de pas être tout seul
l'étudiante dispose de son étagère dans
la cuisine pour ses produits
alimentaires dans sa chambre et là des
meubles pour ranger ses affaires
j'ai fait ma déco perso fatigue et j'ai
aussi une petite salle de bain et ça
c'est super parce que j'ai aussi mon
indépendance au niveau de la salle de
bain c'est juste quand je sors je là
prévient le week-end quand tu te bats
comme ce week-end où je vais sur paris
je les préviens aussi pour me dire que
je vais pas rentrer dans le week-end
seulement due
lingway lui s'il va passer le week-end
tout seul depuis 2010 elle accueille
chez elle des étudiants pour
l'association ensemble2générations je
pense que c'est difficile pour eux aussi
de se loger
bien que moi je ne je n'offre pas le jeu
prend gratuit pour moi c'est c'est une
bouffée de jeunesse ambre depuis le peu
de temps kelly là elle m'a déjà aidé sur
internet parce qu'on a eu des problèmes
de connexion elle est beaucoup plus à
l'aise quand je suis en liga avec avec
la les dépanneurs ambre a aussi aidé
lucile pour remettre en place la
jardinière sur le balcon en 2017
ensemble2générations a déjà formé plus
de 75 binôme dans le département fanny
chantreuil d'une rapide questions sur le
logement étudiant à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qu en est-il
on sait que c'est difficile de se loger
à paris très difficile qu'en est-il à
saint quentin en yvelines est ce que les
étudiants trouvent facilement est ce que
les loyers sont chers ou alors ça va il
ya deux systèmes le logement et les
logements privés les logements publics
le crous quel instant ce qui permet
d'avoir des logements pour les étudiants
nous on a des élus là bas qui suivent
les dossiers pour que les étudiants
trouvent en tout cas un logement donc
encore aujourd'hui il ya des démarches
qui sont en cours tout le monde n'a pas
un logement mais mais pas de difficulté
on va dire particulièrement
insurmontable sur le territoire non et
il ya eu un appel à l'université la
région a fait construire des logements
en avance il ya quelques années en fait
par l'arrivée de nouvelles écoles comme
l'estaca sur le territoire de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
merci fanny chantreuil d'être venu en
plateau d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes du coup
présidente de l'interassociation
fédération d'associations allié au
syndicat fage merci à vous merci
beaucoup
on passe maintenant à l'actualité de la
semaine
[Musique]
mardi plus d'une centaine de personnes
se sont réunies devant l'abattoir de
houdan des militants ont répondu à
l'appel lancé par l'association 269 life
libération animale
le mouvement était organisée sur 65
sites en belgique au canada et même en
australie sur ces images vous voyez
l'opération menée dans les yvelines
l'objectif était d'alerter la population
sur les conditions traitement des
animaux écouter les mots d'une militante
de l'association au micro de camille
lambert une association antispécistes
c'est à dire qu'on est pour la
libération de tous les animaux tous les
êtres vivants et contre leur
exploitation
ce soir donc du coup c'est vraiment une
nuit spéciale c'est vraiment un
événement qui est partout partout dans
le monde dans plusieurs villes de france
et c'est vraiment un recueillement pour
tous les animaux des abattoirs le tollé
a débuté durant l'été le gouvernement a
annoncé la baisse drastique de
l'envelope financières dédiées aux
contrats aidés jugé inefficace et
coûteux par l'exécutif un avis que ne
partagent pas les collectivités
territoriales qui utilisent largement ce
dispositif remplir certaines de leurs
missions c'est le cas du service espaces
verts du département des yvelines
reportage de nicolas landry et accèdent
au web elle à cet endroit là nous avons
les fraisiers framboisiers
desgroseillers et même des cassissiers à
56 ans bernadette déborde s'occupe du
potager biologique du domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles agent immobilière
elle décide de se reconvertir dans
l'horticulture
après une formation au chef elle signe
un contrat aidé en janvier 2017 avec le
conseil départemental
je vois vraiment pas comment on pourrait
comment dire arrêter une disposition
comme celle là parce qu'elle a quand
même contribué à ramener sur le marché
du travail
beaucoup de personnes que l'on croyait
perdus entre 2016 et 2017
plus de 700 contrats aidés ont été
signés par le département plusieurs
postes dans les collèges au service
espaces verts ou dans les services
administratifs ce type de contrat c'est
20 heures de travail 6 heures de
formation un dispositif devant permettre
aux bénéficiaires du rsa un retour à
l'emploi
l'intérêt c'est aussi de les former et
d'avoir une formation qualifiante et si
possible une formation diplômante
ce qui fait qu'à la fin de son contrat
avec l'accompagnement qui activity
pouvait faire ça permettait à ces gens
là de retrouver soit un emploi soit de
retrouver une formation peut-être plus
performante qui correspond à leur vrai
projet professionnel pour un contrat
aidé la charge financière mensuelle du
département s'élève à 490 euros pour
l'état elles représentent entre 300 et
400 euros par mois le gouvernement
voulant supprimer ce dispositif les
collectivités devraient compenser la
participation budgétaire de l'état
ensuite dire que ça coûte cher oui
incontestablement
mais ça ne pourra pas être porté par les
collectivités si parallèlement on
continue à retirer de l'argent en
collectivité en 2016 les yvelines estime
avoir enregistré une baisse de 9 % des
bénéficiaires du rsa
grâce aux contrats aidés le département
qui faisait également l'actualité ce
mercredi avec l'annoncé d'une première
en france et le déploiement de d'ici 2
ans de 4 mille caméras dans les 116
collèges du territoire et dans les
casernes de pompiers ces appareils
seront reliés entre eux un poste central
avec sur place au moins six agents pour
détecter les mouvements de foule ou les
signaux anormaux les précisions de karl
olive vice président de conseil
départemental investissement de 13
millions dans les 116 collèges du
département dans les casernes de
pompiers notamment tout simplement pour
créer une plate forme mutualisée d'image
de vidéoprotection dans un espèce de
maillage de logiciels robotisée qui fait
que des cures un moule dans un mouvement
de foule dans tous ces endroits se sera
directement opérationnels dans ce centre
de supervision urbain efficacité
réactivité aujourd'hui dans le pays en
état d'urgence ce qui est nécessaire
évidemment c'est la réactivité par
rapport à des incidents de plus ou moins
grande importance
mercredi c'était la journée mondiale
dédiée au tourisme l'occasion de faire
le point sur le secteur dans les
yvelines
selon une enquête du département 80 %
des professionnels sont satisfaits de la
période estivale pour évoquer le sujet
nous recevions joséphine coleman ce
berger sur notre plateau mardi soir vice
président du conseil départemental en
charge du tourisme
extrait n'a eu un retour alors un retour
de d'un tourisme international
il faut le dire ils avaient tendance à
fuir la clientèle étrangère est tendance
iphone alors fuir c'est un mot peut-être
un peu fort et en tout cas une
inquiétude certes une inquiétude on se
rend compte que il ya une confiance qui
est fait vis-à-vis des professionnels du
tourisme et aussi je dirais de tout ce
qui est encadrement au niveau de la
sécurité mais par rapport à 10 est cité
à ces lieux donc c'est plutôt bon signe
on a vraiment des signes très positifs
non seulement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure sur des personnes qui viennent
d'ile-de-france sur des sites reconnus
plutôt sur la localité proche
et puis aussi sur tout un tas un secteur
international on a pu constater une
véritable mot ça et vous l'aurez donc
compris joséphine colin ce berger était
sur notre plateau mercredi soir
atmosphère tendue cette semaine à
maurepas autour du café de la plage de
nombreux morts patients s'opposent à la
nouvelle politique de la ville
concernant la salle de spectacle fini
les têtes d'affiché place désormais à la
scène locale mardi soir le conseil
municipal était particulièrement agité
le point avec mélanie poker et aurélie
rose un concert improvisé lors du
conseil municipal de maurepas l'image
n'est pas banal plus d'une centaine de
personnes s'étaient déplacées pour
montrer leur mécontentement contre la
nouvelle orientation culturelle du café
de la plage leurs craintes
la fermeture progressive du lieu j'ai
commencé là-bas en tant que bénévole et
maintenant je suis technicienne lumière
et c'est aussi grâce au café de la plage
que je fais ce métier
j'ai pas envie que ce genre de lieux
fermés
pour moi faut que ça continue pour la
municipalité pas de fermeture du café de
la plage mais en raison d'une baisse des
dotations de l'état
la programmation a été réorganisé le
lieu est désormais dédié aux expositions
aux actions culturelles et à la
promotion des artistes locaux me paraît
important en tout cas de faire
comprendre que le café de la plage et
bien sûr utilisé entre autres par le
cobalt pour réunir les groupes qui le
souhaitent puissent toutes les musiques
de groupes locaux
vous pensez bien que
nous avons besoin comme dans toutes les
structures déficiences de mutualisation
et c'est ce que nous avons voulu faire
un message qui n'a pas vraiment réussi à
convaincre les manifestants
le fermer pendant quatre mois le
réouvrir pendant une date leur fermer
pendant quatre mois et le réouvrir
pendant une date à partir du moment où
il ya plus d'équipés en place parce que
c'est le cas et à partir du moment où ça
ouvre aussi peu c'est à dire trois fois
basses et fermé
si on fait une saison culture avait que
trois dates dans l'année je sais pas
trop ce que ça veut dire mais l'année
prochaine on sait très bien que ça dit
rabah n'y avait pas assez de personnes
donc du coup ils vont du coup ils vont
ils vont se dire bon ben on va le faire
mais comme ça c'est réglé
face à cette action
la municipalité a proposé aux
manifestants de solliciter un rendez
vous individuel 25 % c'est le taux de la
semaine et c'est le taux d'yveline ans à
dives linois excusez moi qui ai sera
âgée de plus de 60 ans en 2040 une
donnée qui confère une importance
particulière aux lieux d'accueil des
seniors à saint quentin en yvelines une
convention de partenariat vient d'être
signé pour garantir une deuxième vie au
site du mes rentes et à magny les
hameaux reportage de mélanie poké après
les difficultés financières de géronde
icap l'avenir s'est éclairci au mes
rentes et une convention vient d'être
signée entre l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et l'association
pour l'insertion l'éducation et les
soins cinq ans qu'a fait ou
l'investissement nécessaire sur
sur match avec un bon maintenant loue
ses bâtiments un prix attractif puisque
comme je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
100 euros du mètre carré par rapport à
166 euros sur sur le marché et puis va
aider aussi au démarrage dans le dans le
financement on investit c'est à dire
comme attendre qu'il faut remettre aux
normes à la cuisine c'est c'est la
communauté d'agglo qui va le faire et
puis après on va donner trente mille
euros au départ puis 20000 du 10000 à un
financement sur trois ans avant que le
domaine deviennent autonomes
financièrement le mes rentes et est
depuis 2010 des personnes dépendantes
accueil de jour aide à domicile ou
encore accueil des malades d'alzheimer
une dizaine de partenaires vont
travailler ensemble et là on a
absolument tout ce qui peut se faire sur
tout ce qui peut prendre en charge les
glissements tout ce qui peut aider à une
meilleure prise en charge de l'isthme je
pense que là c'est vraiment un c'est
vital la mutualisation le transfert de
compétences transfert d'informations des
expertises c'est vraiment c'est ce
qu'ils feront l'avenir une école
d'ergothérapie doit ouvrir en septembre
2010 8 90 étudiants seront attendus 300
personnes devraient être accueillis
d'ici trois ans c'est la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo retour de l'information en
direct lundi à 18h sur tv 78 d'ici là
restez informés et connecté grâce à
notre site internet et nos applications
atv 78
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]